happy birthday Tim McGraw the singer
turns up 50 years old this week I'm
looking at 50s being the new 35 and to
celebrate his wife Faith Hill shared
this steamy snap captioned and never
better baby we are so proud of we're
always proud of him in honor of the big
day we are taking a look back at some of
our favorite 80 moments with Tim and
faith I got a good day tonight he works
really hard and he's very focused and
he's chosen great roles and workers and
amazing actors I'm very proud of it we
all are to be on stage for her and hear
her sing every night it's pretty special
because you you know we don't see it
very often we don't get to hear her sing
very often especially live so every
night I really just look forward to
hearing her and trying to keep up with
her which is the biggest problem for me
well the reason to go out together is
because it's the most fun we ever have
it's well right yeah I mean it I think
so I think you know it's a lot of fun
somebody have so much fun the stay on
the side of the stage and get to see her
singing and anybody gets to come to this
show and gets to see her saying that's a
rare treat I think she looks hot myself
is it like I'm queen for a day what
happens in your family I'm clean every
day it's her world I'm just living I
gotta train these kids right and the
memories that we've created every time
we've gone out it's just been some of
the best memories of our career to be
able to share that with someone not only
that you admire as a professional but
also is your best friend and your
spen I mean it never ever gets old and
never take it for granted
um never don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]